when you end up on the Clippers
being a guy who's from where you're from
playing in La obviously not for the
Lakers but playing for the clippers for
sure you guys have a very very
entertaining team
um but was it like how much of the like
extra [__] did you have to deal with
being home
all of it uh you know what like playing
for the Clippers like and I never really
talk about that [__] because people
always talk about Dunleavy or Donald
Sterling right you know what I mean but
just playing for the Clippers like my
mission when I left golden state was
like all right I know the Clippers are
the Clippers right
coming back home to hopefully do what I
did in Golden State I told Golden State
give me three years you know what I mean
would be in the playoffs if we get the
right people around you know what I mean
like that's what I like that's what I
wanted to do so coming here it was like
yeah if I can get the Clippers to the
playoffs if I can turn the Clippers
around then it'll be a whole different
story you know what I mean so historical
at that point it would have been
historical
um and so like that was kind of like my
mission it was like I need to get
through those first three years
because the first three years is all
[__] you know what I mean you gotta
clean up you know all of just negative
[__] that be going around and you got to
protect your teammates and then you
gotta build your teammates to where they
feel like they can walk in like we
walking in the season and like it's just
us you know what I mean and then it's us
and the coaches and then everybody else
it's our family you know what I mean and
I think with the Clippers it was just
that [__] was just hard bro that [__]
was just hard because it was a lot of
racism sexism uh backstabbing people
telling lies snitching and [__] I was
like man I thought we came to work to
play basketball so all of the Donald
Sterling [__] was very accurate
extremely uh extremely accurate you know
um
I mean besides him you know being like a
piece of [__] in the scum of the earth
like he's actually that speaking of
extorted he got shook down for real
shorty had him on the camera on video
yeah she did him dirty but but he
deserved it hell yeah he deserves he
deserved way more than that bro you know
what I mean you deserve a lot worse than
that uh
um it's crazy because I I went from
having this of like like a genuine like
love for the Warriors growing up as a
kid they were kind of like that fun team
to always watch and then obviously the
error of you Michael Petrus uh Barnes uh
J Rich was such a dope error but then
fast forward to this whole last like
decade of basketball
I [__] cannot stand these Warrior
fans now again because they knew they're
new yeah listen I lived in Tampa Florida
I was doing radio in Tampa at the time
when the Steph Curry and and the LeBron
and [__] was happening and I'm in Tampa
and all of a sudden there's just this
influx of Hardcore Warriors fans in the
middle of Florida amazing and I'm like
where were y'all when Mitch Richmond was
there and Chris Mullins yeah Baron Davis
but it's crazy because you have such
like a place in Bay Area history in
Warrior history what is it like for you
to kind of you like the Warriors are
kind of like a forgotten franchise and I
feel like you helped kind of
re-establish them on the map
but now they're like the franchise yep
what's that like to kind of just witness
like it's amazing man uh you know I just
consider myself the curse breaker you
are the curse breaker I am definitely
the curse breaker uh and I you know I
just kind of like I love watching the
Warriors play right obviously they play
the right way I'm a huge Steph Curry fan
yeah I never forget sand to the Warriors
like when I sign with the Clippers like
y'all don't even like y'all gonna forget
about me like this kid is he's next he's
your future
um and when they win the championship I
feel like I win too you know what I mean
uh and you know I was I would say just
for us with the We Believe Squad and me
in the Bay Area it wasn't just the on
the court it was off the court it's
being accessible to the people at
Oakland San Francisco in the hood right
and corporate in Tech and so like you
know the Bay Area to me is home and
that's hard to say for La dude you know
what I mean but it's like I got I got
real family real real people who take
care of me you know what I mean uh in
the Bay Area and so like whether I'm in
LA or the bay is you know there's no
difference and there's definitely no
hate you know what I'm saying in between
anymore so you know my goal was just
when I went to Golden State was like yo
like we got to establish ourselves as
somebody you know what I mean like we
can't just be like the dead corpse you
know what I mean you know the Pacific
Division we got to have at least a style
so if we get beat like [__] is
like oh good game you know what I mean
like y'all got game you guys made this
work yeah but when I when I got there
that [__] was dead it was a you know it
was just like a lot of dead energy and
dudes didn't even want to play
basketball so for me it was like how the
[__] don't you want to play basketball
this is like how you relieve your stress
your mental health all that [__] like
basketball was that and so once we kind
of like got to a point I think the city
was just like hold on like we got people
who actually care yeah because nobody
like before whether you wanted to be
there or not you didn't know because
they just kept trading coaches and
players in and out yeah it was a coach
for you guys right Don Nelson uh Mike
Montgomery was the coach when I first
got there
and then we had a little success at the
end of the year and then they brought
him back uh which was a bad move for the
second year
um and he start coaching you know what I
mean which is yeah
not probably something he didn't really
do well uh well he's a good dude um
and then Don Nelson came in after Mike
Montgomery for the fire yeah we believe
here yeah crazy and then we believe a
year Doug it was crazy uh you know we
sucked that year the whole year I mean
you guys are the eight seeds you guys
snuck into the playoffs barely snow
right like uh
uh at all at All-Star break there was
like we were the odd person out kind of
like the Lakers this year yeah a lot
like how the Lakers were they were the
13th seed at the All-Star that's exactly
where we were and then all of a sudden
we just
you hit a run like we figured it out you
know what I mean like were you there the
year that Steph got drafted or was that
in the offseason
yeah so uh we missed the playoffs
I go to the Clippers
the Clippers have a bad year the
Warriors have a bad year the Warriors
draft Steph Curry
you know Tim pick I think